foreign
Regina is in Las Vegas Nevada hi Regina
how are you
hi Gabe hi Christina happy holidays to
both of you you too how can we help
um I have a question and it's going to
be a Dave what would you do in my shoes
um I have a debt of 6 800 total in
following the baby steps working
desperately hard three jobs I have a
specific debt that is owed to my
ex-husband of Seventeen hundred dollars
he has threatened to take me back to
court and to incur fees on this debt I
do owe him the money I fell behind
because I owed him 150 a month and
unfortunately I was down with covid so
he is now threading threatening to take
me back to court and then they actually
add on fees and interest
I want to kind of jump off the baby
steps pay him from a loan at a 401k
and get rid of him and get him off the
Ledger for the Year what's your thoughts
so you're working three jobs how much
are you paying towards debt each month
with those three jobs
honestly I went from
um having six or seven debts to having
these last two one how much a month are
you paying on debt
um currently I'm paying about five
hundred dollars I'm trying to pay off my
automobile that's the only loan I have
outstanding
and him
and him yes but I want to just pay how
much money do you have in savings
zero I literally have you don't have the
one thousand dollar save that we told
you to have
unfortunately no day I I had an
emergency so I did have to use that okay
what do you own that you can sell
I am I have everything for sale except
for my bed it's online already
um and I'm working on that and it's just
not coming quick enough
what are these three jobs that you're
doing
what type of work is it I don't I I do
uh different lift Port uh platforms like
you know Rideshare platforms and then I
also have a day job
um and then I donate blood
what does the money due to him for child
support
no it's it's attorney fees that I owed
from the pandemic
they extended and extended and extended
and extended and unfortunately I
encourage oh that you owed me for the
pandemic
yes you had to pay your ex's attorney's
fees why
because I had a bad lawyer you and I
have already discussed this
unfortunately okay all right so this
money has been outstanding a while
I it's been I have been consistent until
the last six months I just I fell off
the bandwagon because again I was done
with coven
you weren't down with covet for six
months
yes sir
are you currently working
I am I have a a great job that I work
remote so I can stay with a day job that
I couldn't be with the public and do the
platforms or donate blood
what's the uh what do you make
uh currently I make right around 57 I'm
sorry 47 I make 57 annually when I do
both the other jobs
so you're bringing in
four thousand dollars a month
roughly yeah okay
I also have child support out of that so
it does decrease that quite considerably
you have to pay him child support
yes sir how much
uh it's 350 a month okay
with this Seventeen hundred dollars what
do you feel like is the runway before
you're in trouble with it like how much
longer do you have to pay she's already
waited too late
correct
yeah
if you send him 500 a month for three
months he'll lay off because he can't
even get a court hearing before then
he's probably already had the paperwork
submitted he's that person all right
well you're the person that worries
about him being that person more than he
is that person
this guy's been ringing your bell a long
time
I'm tired I'm tired of it already
um
yeah that's why I want to get rid of him
yeah he's not going to get rid of him he
pay him 350 a month till your kid is
grown
so he's in your life and your kid is in
your great hope
absolutely yeah uh so duber's in the
picture you're just not getting rid of
him
tell her
uh okay
um I I don't borrow on 401K so that's
why I'm hammering around the edges of
this trying to figure it out have you
tried uh anything like your credit union
to borrow the money
I I can't no and what I would do is just
stop spending on anything and start
sending him 500 a thousand dollars a
month and get rid of him and then catch
up on your other stuff if you get behind
on something so what but you're paying
your car nothing extra or paying it a
month late uh you're paying your light
bill a month late uh you're gonna crimp
down and just get him some money really
really fast and get him out of there but
I'm not going to tell you to go borrow
on your 401k it helps in the short term
but long term it's going to cause you
all kinds of problems